hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
impact of global surveillance on
diagnostic tools
i am jennifer woods of labrutz and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by global scientific affairs
molecular diagnostics at abbott
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the process or
please
follow the process to obtain your
credits by clicking on the continuing
education credits window
i'd like to now welcome our speaker dr
gavin cloherty head of infectious
disease research
diagnostics at abbott dr clardy
you may now begin your presentation
thanks for the kind introduction and
thanks everybody for joining us today
um the title of my talk is the impact of
global surveillance on diagnostics
the agenda what i hope to cover today is
uh to discuss our global surveillance
program
uh that looks at hiv hepatitis b and
cyrus kobe 2
genetic diversity some molecular
epidemiology that we've conducted
and then give a brief introduction to
abbott's new
pandemic defense coalition that just
launched recently
so avid has been conducting global
surveillance on hiv and hepatitis
for up 28 years for over 25 years
and more recently we've introduced sars
coke ii
uh into surveillance um i think for
obvious reasons there's been a lot of
attention in the media looking at
variants and so we're keenly
interested in understanding how this uh
these variants might impact our
diagnostic tests
so the the premise of this program
that's been running for almost three
decades is to monitor
the emergence of new variants to
establish
well characterized specimen types and
specimen banks
so that we can use this information to
make very robust diagnostic test
so that we understand what strains are
circulating
make sure that the tests that we have on
market
work no matter where an infection is
acquired
no matter where the test is performed
and we also share
this um information with the field
we've published more than 125
peer-reviewed papers
and some of them will more recent ones
we'll review later in this talk
we have a specimen bank of over 70
000 rare specimens that have been
collected from 45 countries on six
continents and that
number continues to grow daily so
looking at some of the milestones of
this program it was initiated in 1994
primarily focusing on hiv and actually
the genesis of this program was
hiv group o which proved problematic for
first generation diagnostic tests this
was a
you know in a way a global wake-up call
which abba took very seriously and
implemented this program to make sure
that we would be aware
of how hiv was changing over time
and in different geographies and as you
can see in this timeline in 2009 we
added
hbv to the global surveillance program
in 2011
we identified the the uh case of
hiv group p which we were only the
second
um group in the world to ever find this
uh this this group
this novel a variant group of hiv
um in 2014 we added hepatitis c
uh which was again another important uh
milestone in the program which also
coincided with a lot of new direct
acting
antiviral drugs coming on the market
very important that
all the diagnostic tests function as
they're supposed to
around the world uh in 20 2015 we
actually identified a novel
human virus called human peggy virus ii
we
we found that in patients who had
hepatitis c
predominantly it was an interesting uh
observation
um we also started looking at hepatitis
delta as a as a co-infection for
hepatitis b
and uh and peggy virus was also added to
our surveillance program so now we had
really
uh hepatitis b hepatitis c hepatitis
delta and this novel peggy virus also
added to our surveillance program
we took a a more public health approach
as well
in making use of
the work that we were doing around the
world
to understand the molecular diversity of
these viruses
to also help inform on prevalence and
some public health
aspects of these epidemics uh regionally
and and and
in specific countries
and as i mentioned we we've also in 2020
added uh stereoscope 2 uh to the
surveillance program
so why is uh a global surveillance
program
important and hiv is a nice illustration
number one it's the
the virus that we've been following and
studying
excuse me studying the most carefully
but this
uh this graphic kind of illustrates it
very nicely that there's been four
distinct zoonotic transmissions of hiv
through
human history and uh illustrated here
with group
m n o and p and if you take
uh group o and uh group m subtype b
they're really
very very different viruses and at the
amino acid level they're only 50 percent
similar so really uh having tests that
are able to
accurately detect and quantify
such diverse viruses is extremely
important
and uh this this program has enabled us
to
understand that level of diversity and a
lot of circulating recombinant forms
that
that are now more predominant in in
various parts of the world
and ensuring that diagnostic tests work
all the time
in addition you know we're showing here
four separate zoonotic
uh transmissions um you have
45 uh you know non-human primate species
that could potentially be reservoirs for
other zoonotic transmissions so we've
got to be
ever vigilant in in our work
the impact of not being vigilant is is
quite uh
stark and quite sobering so this uh
slide starts show
a case study uh of a a group p
that was identified in france um
which really uh you know was was very
surprising in 2004 a 62 year old
cameroonian woman
who was residing in france um came
and was diagnosed as being hiv positive
in a paris hospital by an antibody test
and it was western blot
confirmed but when the
physician went to to conduct a viral
load test
uh with the monitor assay that was
available at the time there was no
detectable viremia in the blood
so this was puzzling and there was
several draws and and
tests performed um over time
so the the the lab had also the avid
real-time hiv assay available so
they then tried they tested these
samples with the real-time assay and
they found a viremia
of about 4.4 to 5.3 log copies per ml
so this woman did have an active hiv
infection and confirmed the
the architect combo results as positive
the lab tried to do some additional
investigation to understand what was
going on
uh to try and see if if it was maybe a
group o
infection or some divergent group m
and uh that may have some mutations to
the primers and probes and what
actually they found was quite surprising
they had uh successfully amplified and
sequenced the genome
of a new group a group p which came from
gorillas and
and that explains the the image here on
the left hand side where you've got the
eiffel tower indicating paris and
the gorilla indicating where this group
p had originally
come from so what's impressive here
uh in addition to the discovery of a new
hiv
group is that the architect
combo assay and the abbot real-time
viral load assay both worked in this
very divergent
virus without any pre-existing knowledge
of that virus or its sequence
the way these tests are are developed
relying
heavily on our experience with this
global surveillance program
and knowledge of the diversity of these
viruses
enabled us to build a test that was
resilient and robust enough to pick up
this new group uh of hiv
so kind of a testament to why we do this
surveillance program
in addition uh there was some uh
in some media interest
in this uh paper that i'm presenting
here where through work we had performed
in the democratic republic of congo
where we were sequencing
hiv and hepatitis strains found there
and we processed about 10 000 samples
we actually identified a hiv
group m subtype l which which enabled
this subtype to be officially classified
and this was the first new hiv subtype
that had been
named in 20 years so this was a kind of
an important event and created a
considerable amount of media interest
and also important to note that again
all the abbott
tests were able to detect this subtype l
so it's not as i mentioned just hiv that
this program
focuses on we also look at hepatitis b
hepatitis c
sars and have delta i'm highlighting
here an interesting paper where we
looked in
samples we had received from thailand
and we were
able to identify a novel genotype eye
which is a very rare strain and it has
only been it had not been previously
characterized in thailand
so this now is present in thailand that
may be circulating and
would instigate additional interest and
research into understanding more of the
genetic diversity in this part of
southeast asia
so for hepatitis b just like hiv there
is
a danger in not being vigilant and not
developing tests that are
to genetic diversity not understanding
that that genetic diversity that may be
out there
and so in this uh study that was uh
published this is not an avid study but
it was uh published by hendricks
hendrickson and now they looked at
hepatitis b
in dialysis patients and they found
a case of a patient who had been
vaccinated effectively had an anti-hbs
uh uh titer of 82 so it should have been
effectively vaccinated was
hepatitis b surface antigen negative uh
when and originally
uh tested and so this person then would
have been dialyzed and
uh common units uh instruments with
other
other patients and later on it was
identified
that this patient was surface antigen
positive when they were tested with
the abbott architects platform and when
they went back they found
through archive samples multiple
instances where this
person had been positive and um had
not been detected using a different test
and the survey
found that nine out of 23
institutions or labs that were testing
these types of samples did not use tests
that were robust to common surface
antigen mutations
so again i think it's important to
be ever vigilant because if you're not
you could in this case
risk transmitting virus to other people
who are at risk or missing infections
and missing opportunities to treat
people
appropriately
moving on to to tsar's curve too i think
anybody who's not familiar with
stereoscope 2 or
you know where it came from must be
living in a cave for the last year but
this slide does
illustrate that it's a novel beta
coronavirus
um incubation period is you know roughly
five days but anywhere between two to
fourteen days
uh not always symptomatic but symptoms
usually happen around 12 days
or 10 to 12 days and so you can have
mild to moderate
disease or hospitalization fatalities so
deaths 2.4 million people worldwide it's
a real you know as everybody's aware
this is a tragic
situation um so one of the earliest
efforts
and ways to try and tackle uh the
the pandemics that was was brewing was
to develop a
an assay a molecular assay and in this
case
we're describing here the target
selection
of the abbot uh molecular assay and
we selected the dual target both for
robustness
and redundancy so in case there were
mutations in any region that might
impact one of the regions the other
would be able to amplify
we selected nucleocapsid and rdrp region
of spike
and and again keep in mind that we
developed this assay with one sequence
so we had
just that initial sequence that was um
released
uh we used that and the knowledge that
we had accumulated
over the 30 years of studying diverse
viruses and making
diagnostic tests to select these two
regions that
were the most conserved and we figured
would be the most
conserved moving forward and that's
proving to be the case
so there as as i mentioned there's been
a lot of
interest in stars cover two variants
that have made a lot of uh
impression on the media uh we've heard
about the uk
variant the south african variant the
brazil variant
and these uh we have evaluated very
carefully
in the global surveillance in our global
surveillance program
the mutations are illustrated here on
the right hand side
they they range from nucleocapsid spike
uh open reading regions some are in e as
well
but what's most important from our
perspective
is that we've analyzed in silico through
bioinformatics pipelines and predictions
etc
that these the abbott tests are not
impacted by these mutations
and actually in the case of the uk
variant and the south african variant
we've physically tested
samples uh containing these variants and
found that they're accurately detected
that there's no impact
on the on the performance of the tests
in addition we're continuing to be ever
vigilant
and sequence samples that uh we source
from all over the us and and globally
and some
are illustrated here in south africa
we're collaborating with crisp in south
africa
working with the folks in in the united
kingdom
in senegal uh in brazil and canada
to really keep an eye on how these
viruses are changing over time and that
list continues to
extend as well as it's just a
representation
in illinois we've been sequencing as she
found some
uk strain floating around it in in the
uk
in the illinois population i'm sorry
sequencing in california through our
collaboration with ucsf
um getting sourcing samples from
wisconsin and michigan
and and putting that with chicago to get
a feel of what's going on in the midwest
and
sequencing samples from new york where
we found the new york variant
as well as the new york variant with the
e 484k
variant as well which is again
in quite a few samples that's a concern
so this is an ongoing effort
and on the right hand side i think we'll
see a graphic
of the clades and diversity we found
in our early study basically back in
march to see what was circulating
and what was interesting is that the
clades that were the samples that we
sequenced
from the east coast and michigan
reflected more of the european uh kind
of feel and the ones we we sequenced
from
uh further west were um
more of the asian feel and then chicago
was a bit of a melting pot of both so
it's an
interesting illustration of of human
movement i guess
and we've developed novel techniques
to make sure that we're able to sequence
even low tighter samples so
we've applied what we call an x-gen
approach to hiv and hepatitis and that's
using
a an enrichment using probes
oligos that are specific to that um
to that pathogen to kind of pull them
out preferentially
and sequence them and we do that in in
samples where we've got a low
tider and it enables us to get whole
genomes in about 90 percent of cases
or even more down to about
log 3.5 and most of the genome
in samples that are even lower lower
viral loads than that
so how does the the the program
works through partnering with uh
collaborators
around the world um and and some of them
are listed
here and you can see it's very diverse
from south america
asia africa europe um it's important
to to be aware that we can't do this on
our own and we need to partner with
collaborators all over the world to
understand how viruses are changing
in in real time and across the globe
and the pathway we we use as i mentioned
was collaboration with people who have
access to patient samples whether they
be hospitals or blood banks
we put these samples through a very
rigorous testing algorithm whether it be
with our diagnostic tests we in-depth
sequencing
other analysis should we find something
interesting
all is part of the the package and the
the process that we put in
in place and then if we just discover
something
we make that available that information
available to our collaborators
and also to the general space through
through uh peer-reviewed publications
as i mentioned we've got 25 now
which i think might be an underestimate
at this point but um
so we do share our data with our
collaborators the
data with our collaborators and the
space and then we use this information
it's not just an academic exercise to
constantly refine
improve design either our existing
tests or new tests that may prove useful
so it's important to keep in mind that
these viruses are constantly evolving so
our diagnostics
needs to constantly evolve to keep up
switching gear a little bit to molecular
epidemiology i think it's important as i
mentioned
in a previous slide to keep in mind that
we can do more
with the information that and and the
samples that we're collecting and the
work that we're doing around the world
so one
effort is to try and dovetail this to
get some
epidemiology information out by
partnering and collaborating with
other investigators um so i mentioned
previously we talked about the hiv group
m subtype l
that we found in the democratic republic
of congo and through our collaborations
with carol macarthur
uk umkc and the university protestant
of congo we've been
able to characterize and test
more than 10 000 samples have been
collected over a few years
and one of the things that we observed
through our diagnostic algorithm
was that there was a discordance between
the number of hiv combo positives and
hiv viral load positives so we had a
higher proportion than expected that
were antibody positive
that we couldn't get any uh viral load
or was very low
so we started to investigate to make
sure that there were no issues with our
diagnostic tests
doing western blots and different pcr
tests and using comparator assays and
stuff
and we found what was was quite uh
interesting we found a very high
percentage
of of these samples look like they came
from elite controllers or suppressors so
people were able to naturally control
the virus themselves
because as part of the enrollments there
was a questionnaire that said
you know were you on therapy but just to
be on the safe side we also
sent samples from mass spec to see if
there were
any evidence of antiretroviral drugs on
board and we did find that actually
quite a
considerable percent i think 40 to 60
percent of them
did have evidence of antiretroviral
drugs so they were excluded
from the analysis but even still we
found approximately
2.7 to 4.3 percent of these samples
who weren't had no evidence of
antiretroviral drugs
but were either low or
negative for viremia and truly antibody
positive
so these would fit the criteria of
presumed
elite suppressors now what we need to do
to
explore this further would be to get
longitudinal samples from these cases
and show that they are continuously
suppressed
and also you know would afford us the
opportunity to look at the
immunology of these these uh
participants to see
how exactly are they doing this normally
you might find point one percent
of a given population might be able to
control the virus naturally or
in some cases we've seen the literature
up to maybe one percent
but never up to four or four point three
percent so it's a quite phenomenal
um finding that we were able to
observation
that we were able to make through this
study in addition
we've been collecting samples for hiv
surveillance
in cameroon for many years so we availed
of this
to go back and look and see how much
hepatitis c we could find
or how much of this new peggy virus we
were able to identify
and so what we found was quite
interesting that the percent
of hepatitis c was roughly about two two
and a half percent
and i had heard you know anecdotally
that it would be
anywhere from eleven to fifteen percent
so this was quite interesting to show
that
with an rna um test uh so not using
any antibody tests our lateral flow
rapid test we were able to show that
um the the prevalence was about two and
a half percent and this was year over
year so these studies were done
um over many years and the data was
consistent
and the samples were collected from a
geographically
diverse uh sites around south cameroon
so what we also found was that there was
a predominance of male
so you'd have up to 3.8 percent
positivity in men
versus women we're about two percent and
also
that there was an age bias so while most
of the samples were coming
from younger people let's say in their
30s
maybe down to their 40s most of the
positives were coming from people who
were in their 60s
50s 60s and and above so there was
definitely an
age cohort effect here and also a gender
bias
so it's very interesting data and we
also found evidence of
the novel peggy virus among uh people
who are hiv
hepatitis b and mhcd uh positive
in in cameroon um but again most of the
uh positives came in in people who were
uh hiv and hep c
we also then decided to leverage again
these samples that we had collected from
from cameroon and look at
about 1900 samples that have been
collected that were surfaced
hepatitis b surface antigen positive and
and see if they
also carried a hepatitis delta evidence
of a hepatitis delta infection
and we found to our amazement that 46
were antibody positive for delta which
led us to then
interrogate further to see in these
samples how many were
hepatitis delta rna positive and we
found that almost 35
of the hep b's were hep delta positive
now this is
incredibly important from a public
health perspective because the prognosis
for a hep delta hpv co-infection is
quite poor
with money or most uh going on to to
develop cirrhosis and potentially cancer
and and high rates of morbidity and
mortality so it was important to be able
to make the cameroonian
uh folks aware of what we had found and
so we published this this data
it was uh other data was later uh
reproduced
by i think the institute pastor looking
at the entire country of cameroon and
they reproduced what we found in south
cameroon
and actually found that north cameroon
the prevalence of delta was actually
quite
a lot lower so it's important to to look
to
to fine-tune the geography that you're
searching
we've also been busy looking at novel
biomarkers for hepatitis b
trying to facilitate a greater
understanding of this virus and and
maybe
enable uh novel curative therapies or
different approaches
to treating that virus and in this slide
here we see
you know the the life cycle of a
hepatitis b virus as it enters the cell
moves to the nucleus
uh gets transformed unpackaged into
covalently closed circular dna
and then is transcribed and translated
it also shows
where novel are not level the standard
of care nucleoside
analog therapy interacts and interrupts
the life cycle so it really
impacts at the end where the hepatitis b
rna is converted into dna before being
released into the the the
blood as a uh gain particle
so what's important here to keep in mind
is that this therapy
does not impact anything that happens
upstream so it has no
impact on the generation of hepatitis b
rna
its encapsulation and potentially its
release into the plasma so we developed
a test to to have a look at that and and
on the right hand side here
you'll see with a standard hpv dna
assay that the usual trajectory that the
viral load increases
to a set point so you've got a dna viral
load level
and then as you apply a nucleoside
analog therapy the dna declines but as i
mentioned
previously these this nucleotide analog
therapy has no impact on the production
or release of hpv rna so rna actually
remains
uh can remain pretty stable over time
and then
might decline as you get
an immunological response or some other
mode of action that can impact the
course of the infection
okay so i think here we i
want to show the uh assay that was
developed
uh for the m2000 assay it's a research
use only assay and it's uh
designed to be automated we standardized
it to the who dna standard so that we
can have
some kind of understanding of the units
and what we're seeing so one unit
of rna is roughly equivalent to one iu
of dna based on the who standard
the limit of detection of the test is 44
units per mill
and we published these findings in
hepatology in 2018.
important to note that we actually have
a dual target approach here too
and that we did this for multiple region
reasons one
was so that there would be redundancy in
case there was any mutations that would
impact the detection and amplification
of this target
uh the other was uh to try and
understand if
what we were finding in the plasma was
entire pre-genomic rna
or if it was pre-genomic rna and other
subspecies of rna the expectation there
is that if there were these other
species present
that we would be able to see it by a
divergence in the signals that we got
from the
the x and the core because both of them
have different floor force
by comparison this automated test
is significantly more sensitive than the
previously manual race-based method that
was
published by van bommel and hepatology
had a limited detection of roughly 300
copies per mil
and so there's been a lot of research
done to understand the relative
performance of these two tests and the
clinical utility and i'll talk about
that just uh
shortly so one interesting question that
had been
posed earlier was whether rna
was present in the plasma as kind of
like an accident or
was it there you know routinely
and and reliably so we looked at a
couple of serial conversion panels so
where we had uh sequential samples from
patients who had
become infected as they went through the
course of either
resolving that as in the top two panels
here
or going chronic as in the bottom panel
and what was remarkable for us to see
was that the rna was present almost from
the start
um and it was present at about one and a
half
to 1.7 logs lower concentration than the
dna
so it was there not not as abundantly
but it was there from the start
which would imply that this is a routine
uh routinely found in plasma and was not
some kind of accident
biological accident it's also
interesting to see that you know when
the patient goes chronic
that the rna tracts very closely with
the dna
in terms of how much is found in that
patient and also that the x and core
targets were found in pretty much the
exact same concentration so did not
appear
that there was any difference between
pre-genomic rna our pre-genomic plus
which
implies that the predominant species of
hbv-rna
in the samples is pre-genomic rna
so looking at the clinical utility of
this mark
a study that was uh published by kerry
and al
um from king's college looked at
patients
who were on nucleoside analog therapy
were suppressed
and whether the question from the
physicians is is it safe to stop
nucleoside analog therapy
because there can be the risk that the
liver will flare that you'll get
a flare which can in fact be quite
serious and
and even fatal so they characterized a
flare as
uh no to minimal as uh less than two
of the upper limit of normal uh whether
it's mild would be
between you know less than five upper
limit of normal
and greater than 10 was a severe flare
as you can see
on the left hand side hepatitis b dna
was negative
by default so the person was on
nucleoside analog therapy and
they had been suppressed for some time
so this marker is no longer telling you
anything and does not predict
whether or not somebody would have a
flare but
and and similarly surface antigen was
also positive
in all of these samples at a very
relatively similar rate so again
did not predict a flare however
the hpv rna assay when it was positive
was a very good marker of whether or not
somebody may
experience a severe a severe flare after
stopping therapy
so in the patients who had no flare
and those had a mild flare the rna was
not detectable
but in all cases where there was a flare
rna was still detectable and
quantifiable
in these cases that shows that
replication was still ongoing in the
hepatocytes
and so um this person these people were
at risk of a flare
in addition a similar study uh there
were
excuse me 19 patients who are on
long-term suppressive nucleoside
analogue therapy
um they had a you know negative dna
uh they were stopped again so that the
the question is could pre-genomic rna
or the presence of anti-hbs the
predictors of who might relapse
and as you can see here the uh hepatitis
b dna was negative
in those who pre in the preceding
samples
and those who who relapsed
also there was no uh benefit to
to looking at surface antigen uh i'm
sorry not surface antigen
uh core antigen uh but in this case
where hpv rna
was still positive both of these
patients did relapse
and also what was interesting was that
when you had a robust
anti-hbs uh result um
they did not relapse and the patients
the two who relapsed did not have a very
uh robust anti-hbs response
and they were also viremic here when you
you see the hpd rna
results
so in short the the hpv
seems to be an interesting tool for
studying the natural
history of hepatitis b it does appear to
have clinical utility
in predicting whether it's safe to stop
somebody treat
who's on a long-term nucleic analog
therapy
and whether or not the person should be
stopped in terms of their risk
of um having a relapse over time so if
rna is still positive
um these people may be at risk of an alt
flare and they may be at risk of relapse
so it's probably best to keep them on
treatment this test is also being used
extensively in clinical trials to try
and understand
its role and performance with novel
therapeutic
compounds and approaches
so moving to a slightly different topic
i want to make you aware of a
program that abbott has launched in the
last couple of weeks now
the name might imply that this is a
response to the sars cove to
pandemic but in fact this program has
been
in development for uh several years
and uh in fact was delayed by the
pandemic the launch was delayed by the
pandemic so the time is right i think
for um this to to take to take
to take flight so it's called the abbott
pandemic defense
uh coalition and the intent
uh is to as the name it would imply
to try and prevent another pandemic
from taking hold so we've seen
the effect of the current pandemic we
have ebola now
you know popping up again in the
democratic republic of congo
zika ripped around the planet a couple
of years ago we had sars
the original stars and mers outbreak so
these are coming at an
increasing frequency and we've had a
couple of
near misses in terms of pandemic
profiles
there's also an amazing amount of
undiagnosed
illness so if we look here in acute
respiratory cases maybe 15 to 30 percent
are undiagnosed up to 70 percent of
meningitis encephalitis
gastroenteritis up to 50 go undiagnosed
so
is there a pathogenic uh or pathogen
that is that could be the root cause of
all of these illnesses that that
go undiagnosed this was the
these were the questions that were on
our mind as we were building
uh the capabilities to launch this
coalition
over the last several years
so it's important to just make the point
that this is not an academic exercise
this is a scientific exercise sure but
it's really a public health partnership
that's dedicated to try to
identify early some threats that could
pose
a a risk of a pandemic and to respond
to try and prevent that so outbreaks
might happen but hopefully
we can prevent a pandemic
the approach that we're taking is is a
holistic approach
so as many others are we're looking to
see if we can
uh find pathogens that may pro
provide a fertile ground for a potential
outbreak or pandemic
but in in addition to just identifying
these threats
we're going to be very active in rapidly
developing molecular
and serological tools through whether it
be through
core lab or rapid tests that can then
be deployed to our partners around the
world to try and
understand what we found if we identify
something
in africa or in thailand or in brazil
do we see it in chicago do we see it in
france do we see
where else in the world do we see it in
australia do
where else do we see these this these
evidence of this
pathogen so that kind of translational
research is really critical to inform
public health
to the level of risk and then if we do
identify something that is a potential
risk we can then manufacture these tests
on scale as we did for stars code 2 and
try and
you know prevent an outbreak from
becoming an epidemic
and i guess you know i was asked before
what uh a potential book if i was to
write a book on this in a couple of
years and i think the title of it would
be
pandemics that never happens that would
be my the the title that i would hope we
would have
so the network will include um
infectious disease experts around the
world
and the the the requirement is is quite
high we need these experts because we
need to identify
unique cases cases that are unusual
cases that are a potential risk trends
among populations
things we might want to investigate
further we also
want to partner with labs
and and uh collaborators that have a lot
of technical expertise
in some parts of the world uh samples
can't be shipped we need to be able to
do this work
on site and actually it's preferable in
terms of timeliness
to be able to do this work locally so
that's that's another key
um uh characteristic that we're looking
for
in in partners that we're joining today
and so in summary you know we talked
about the the need for
uh elite infectious disease expertise
and a high level of
of technical expertise to do the work
locally where possible
um it's also important that everything
is done in a very
controlled systematic and and high
quality
way from sample collection to storage to
shipping
uh bioinformatics we've invested a lot
of time and effort in building robust
bioinformatic pipelines
that will enable us to identify uh
these potential novel pathogens and also
enable us to rapidly prototype tests
that can be deployed
uh both for the purposes of
understanding
what we've the nature of what we've
discovered and also from a
deployed for public health uh protection
if you like so that we can try and
ring fence any outbreak and prevent
a next pandemic and speed is of the
essence so i think this is a critical
part
point to make that we don't have weeks
and months
and even years as sometimes is the case
when you're developing
uh tests for routine diagnostics we have
to be able to move fast
so i appreciate your time and
i think that's that's all i i have to
present today
thank you
thank you dr clardy for your informative
presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
let's get started our first question is
you mentioned that you used one sorrow
sequence for your molecular assay
what are some of the attributes you look
for when designing assays with limited
sequence availability
well yeah that's a tough one you
try and and draw on the knowledge that
you have
from uh previous uh asset development
activities and
the knowledge we've gained from studying
viruses over the many decades
but usually you're looking for sequences
that
and regions that are unique to the
virus that that you're targeting so you
don't have specificity issues
and um that are highly conserved based
on the the function
um so this was a rather nerve-wracking
experience with stars because we had to
move so quickly with so
some so little information but worked
out okay
thank you dr clarity our next question
here is
with increased pharma interest in in hbv
do you see the relationship between hbv
dna and rna
changing oh gosh my screen jumped okay
changing as new therapies
targeting different hpv pathways become
available
and would these studies need to be
repeated with different drug targets
well i think the the studies will need
to be uh drug target specific and
actually drugs
specific um i think it's interesting to
see
uh we'll have to wait and see basically
we're doing a lot of work looking at
existing nucleoside analog therapy and
new new drugs that are coming to the
market
and as they work in different ways i
think the relationship between hpv rna
and dna and in fact
other markers serological markers like
surface antigen the antigen
correlated antigen are all going to need
to be assessed and it will have to be
done in a very
specific way for the the drugs as they
have different mechanisms of action
thank you dr clardy our next question
here is
is your focus on clinical isolates or
will you also conduct surveillance in
animals and the environment
so our initial focus is on clinical
isolates looking in the in human uh
populations
there's a lot of work adjacent to our
program that's looking at animal
populations where
we'll be you know collaborating and and
having a line of sight
but i think um you know there's a lot of
viruses that
are in animals that that may pose a
threat but the
the there's no guarantee it's a very
difficult thing to tease apart which
ones will make
the jump across so we're trying to
really
stay focused on what is significant
clinically
to try and catch them in in early in
the human population and understand
what's going on there
closer to the threat
thank you dr clarity our next question
here is
why are rna viruses more dangerous than
dna viruses
well i think rna viruses you know they
they tend to
uh well cause more disease it's not
inherent in rna versus dna i think
basically we have to look at the
the viruses and the clinical
consequences that they cause
we will be you know looking at both rna
and
dna viruses in our program as well as
other pathogens
okay thank you dr clardy our next
question
do you or your controllers have
additional follow-up studies planned for
the elite controller study
so we are looking at ways to
uh to to study this topic uh more
closely
will require follow-up and longitudinal
samples
sampling from these patients with their
immune system
these are things that are in discussion
and see how we can
go about making that happen
and our next question i applaud you for
the initiation of the pandemic defense
coalition
is there a certain profile of
institutions you are looking for and how
does one initiate this type of
collaboration so
um i think we we outlined in in the
presentation there you know kind of some
of the characteristics
we need people who have access to clinic
samples and
interesting patient populations
geography is important
expertise we're looking for expert
partners
um and i think the way of connecting can
be through
uh local abbot representatives
or you know directly to myself or
other members in r d but um yeah
i think that's that you can contact your
local avid rep or scientific affairs or
anybody
to to contact to get in touch with us
and our last question here for you today
your surveillance program uses ngs for
sars variant monitoring
what are your thoughts around different
variant detection assays
and is abbott developing a variant or a
sequencing assay
so i think you know sequencing is
critical
in looking for new variants and see
because uh when you
you're if you've got a test that's
specific for certain mutations that have
been very strained defining variants or
mutations then
uh you will miss anything else that's
out there so sequencing remains kind of
the backbone for looking at
emerging new variants i think you can
develop assays
to pick up specific mutations
that's only really clinically relevant
if you're going to do something with
that information in terms of treat
people differently quarantined
you know behave differently so right now
those are kind of epidemiological
tools um i think they're they're they're
there's a few of them that are coming
out
uh and and so we're looking at that in
terms of
whether or not we would build one it it
really depends on the clinical utility
you know in terms of moving it forward
in a regulatory process as opposed to a
research tool
thank you dr clardy do you have any
final comments for our audience
no i'm very grateful for people to who
took the time to to spend this time with
us and and uh participate
in this call and for the interesting uh
questions that that they posed and uh
we're very
open to collaboration if anybody wants
to reach out as
i mentioned through scientific affairs
local reps or directly to us
we look forward to hearing from you
thank you again dr clardy for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor
global scientific affairs molecular
diagnostics at abbott
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye